the kids were crying it said please
don't take my father please don't take
my father
and what's the burden
Brandee was eight years old when her
father was taken from her and her story
is not unique
she's just one of the hundred thousand
American children each year who lose at
least one parent to deportation and now
she's just one of the many children Nora
San Diego provides for I'm the legal
guardian for eight hundred and seventeen
kids yes you heard her correctly
Nora San Diego a Miami resident is
providing for eight hundred and
seventeen US citizen children who have
been affected by parental deportations
most of my kids suffer a lot because
they don't know that if what point of
their life they can be alone because the
father or mother was the boarder or
could be deported family unity is a non
partisan value however mixed status
families bring a unique twist when
dealing with immigration policy should
immigrants who have established American
families be forgiven for their illegal
entry into the country President Obama
says yes it has attempted to address
these issues through executive action
however real and lasting change must
come from Congress and until that
happens many American children remain
uncertain of their family's future the
two major principles of immigration law
of protecting American workers but the
other part is family unification IRA
Kurzban has been a Miami based
immigration lawyer for over 30 years and
what the president is doing is focusing
on that second one and saying if you
have an American citizen child or a
lawful permanent resident trial we're
gonna let you stay here and take care of
your child
that's not something that's on the
government you are illegally here you
lied repeatedly and probably committed a
whole string of other crimes identity
theft and what-have-you perjury tax
fraud and you're now gonna have to pay
for that not by going to jail but just
by going back home to your own country
you can take your little kids with you
but you have to bear the responsibility
for your crimes mark Krikorian is the
director of the Center for Immigration
Studies a think-tank that argues for
Less immigration altogether there's
nothing that prevents immigrants being
deported from taking their kids with
them but immigration lawyers say that's
not true
when illegal immigrants are caught
they're often detained far from where
their families live and are physically
unable to take care of their children
new bonnet are solos el gobierno bah
Cersei cargo de los ninos seeker and
solo sirve go low bangle are displayed
on tiempo Gallup soon once the Child
Protective Services are involved it can
be very difficult for an illegal
immigrant to retain custody of their
children
the question is who takes care of the
child if the child becomes a dependent
on the state and the state has to find a
family that will take care of the child
just like any other American citizen in
2011 at least 50 100 children were in
the foster care system due to parental
deportation this cost the government on
average about $26,000 a year for every
child in foster care
this means that in 2011 the u.s. spent
at the very least a hundred and thirty
three million dollars on foster care for
these children in more recent years that
figure maybe over six hundred million
dollars as the number of children is
estimated to be closer to 15 thousand
Maori occupation Katan un padre por ESO
lo de hond own de nosotros por qué saben
que yo nunca
boyacky dare que las líneas by and as
her introduced a naloxone Devon de estar
con sus hijos e mental mint a van ATAR
con sus hijos es una promesa Camus hecho
tanto padres como las niñas carucha
Ramos para que our own efficacy of
internment these parents have signed a
contract before their deportation
granting nor powers of attorney over
their kids that way if the parents are
deported Nora is there to make sure the
children are placed in good homes with
families or friends they're using this
foster care argument as a wedge to argue
that the parents should be able to stay
but that discussion oh it's not even
appropriate as a political discussion
not because the parents of kids who were
born here shouldn't at some point get
amnesty I mean I don't like it but you
can't rewind the video the problem the
core problem to me is that we haven't
actually created the conditions the
preconditions for that kind of amnesty
we have such a large illegal immigrant
population because our political class
has simply refused
to enforce the existing laws one law
many anti-immigration advocates would
consider not enforcing however is the
Fourteenth Amendment and automatic
citizenship at birth because it's not
just being abused by illegal immigrants
it's being abused by tourists foreign
students have kids here if the graduate
students here for a few years and then
they leave I mean those kids aren't
American this conservative argument
known as the anchor baby argument rests
on the idea that birthright citizenship
encourages people to come to the US
illegally and have children in hopes
that their American child would grant
them benefits or legal status that ended
in 1977 after 1977 your child has to be
21 years old to petition for you so the
concept of somebody coming here and
having a child so the child competition
for them is ridiculous there's no such
thing as an anchor baby anymore studies
showed that most illegal immigration to
the United States is driven by economic
factors not the attraction of birthright
citizenship but for these mixed status
families any economic gain they might
have achieved in the u.s. is stretched
then when deportation enters the picture
statistically it's mostly the father
that gets deported leaving single
mothers struggling to make ends meet
Nora says she can't solve all the
problems her kids face pero las curenci
aza materiales quasis algo que nosotros
podemos supe we're on cuando hay Mucha
difficult ah days para su trellis porque
so mucho los ninos pero es algo que si
podemos hacer para mir lo más importante
que o oy y SI es posible a esta semana
los ninos tengan suficiente comida para
no hacer su kama co membre panel a
dormir comme hombre por que muchas veces
los ninos medicine ESO alguna base a la
linea medicine don't is it is it is
beautiful but sometimes it's so
difficult
miss Adamo sorrows Nino sila Ramos
caucus on the emergencia como por
ejemplo leche cornflake cosas que
necesitan parody are you eat am being
lazy vamos utilises culeros ropa in
algunos casos lo que nem o ke EA guard
emergency approach a necesitan e del
médico los padres a el padre que todavía
que no fue por todo necesita era el
médico in Makena transportatio me miss
have a casa de tarde soon in your comfy
area CK tamo attentive the tolerance of
the dice
she has been a kind of a beacon for
people who know that she is the person
here locally who you can depend on and
she's try to do as best as she can under
the circumstances el gobierno no NOS
ayudan nada nosotros solamente tenemos
you de de nosotros Mythos the pequeñas
donna Sione's de amigo que tiene
negocios OD familiaris y siempre esta
muy necesitan dole ajudada Iglesias de
otras organizaciones de de personas de
la comunidad President Obama's executive
stay on deportations is still in effect
but even if it survives court challenges
brought forth by Republicans it will
still expire in 2016 when Obama leaves
office in order to provide lasting
relief to these American children
Congress needs to enact a more humane
and comprehensive immigration policy
vamos a seguir tocando las puertas de
ambos partidos creo que en ambos partido
sy i personas ha so buenas a que Rico no
sin la controversy onesi y lo su free me
n toes cata need o que pasar la
comunidad in durante muchos Unidos
you